the operation to retake the tanker
happened shortly after 7pm
special forces commandos from the sbs ab
sailed onto the deck from helicopters
hovering above
supported by colleagues who scaled the
side of the ship
the seven hijackers were captured
without being harmed and the ship was
retaken
there would have been two merlin uh mark
fours there have been two wildcats
um and the operation basically is there
to isolate the ship
uh secure the upper deck to make sure
there is no reaction from on board
and then the um sbs um commandos will be
roped on board obviously covered by the
wildcats and
personnel in the helicopters they would
immediately
make sure the crew is safe and then
secure the stairways
uh wherever they are in the ship i think
the operation was all over
in seven minutes i hear from the time it
started
to the seven people being rounded up the
tanker had been stationary a few miles
off the coast of the isle of wight
for most of the day one of the world's
busiest shipping names
she was due to dock in southampton on
sunday morning but started steering
an erratic course shortly after 10 30 am
images from the marine traffic website
showed her zig zagging movement
for almost two hours the stairways began
acting violently when the crew
discovered them and tried to lock them
in a cabin
we don't know what the people on board
were trying to do perhaps they were
trying to threaten to run the ship
aground and
spill the oil of the cargo or perhaps to
try and do something even worse they
seem to come
from the new um center of piracy in the
world which is off
off the west african coast but whether
they were trying to sort of coerce
themselves into the uk which
strikes me a little odd or we're just
trying to sort of carry out some kind of
terrorist attack which perhaps is more
likely
it's hard to say the nave andromeda left
the nigerian port of lagos
on october the 6th it arrived in the
canary islands port of las palmas nine
days later
on october the 15th and left a few hours
later for southampton
it stopped a few miles out south of the
isle of wight
and an exclusion zone was established
and maritime coast guard helicopters
flew over it
for most of the day the flash to bang
as they say in the military was pretty
quick but
these waters the sbs's training ground
they're based just around the coast
in pool and they practice boarding
tankers cargo ships and ferries
on the english channel the whole time so
in that respect
this could not have been a more
convenient location
for an operation of this kind from the
military's point of view this was
textbook and the government will be
pleased it didn't have an ongoing
standoff
in the middle of the english channel a
tricky situation was dealt with
in under 12 hours